[Music]
some people think the top story today is
the big winter storm hitting the East
Coast or maybe the big story is the
Sochi Olympics but judging by local news
across the nation there's an even bigger
story that's sweeping our country it is
19 minutes past the hour welcome back
everybody those without a sweetheart
this Valentine's Day may look to their
smartphone or tablet to help direct
Cupid's arrow their way while those with
a special someone may look to their
mobile device to help them say I love
you those with a special someone may
look to their mobile device to help them
say I love you those are the special
someone may look to their mobile device
to help them say I love you those with a
special someone may look to their mobile
device to help them say I love you those
with a special someone may look to their
mobile device to help them say I love
you those with a special someone may
look to their mobile device to help them
say I love you those with a special
someone may look to their mobile device
to help them say I love you with that
special someone may use their mobile
device to help say I love you
those with one may look to their device
to help them say I love
special someone may look for their
mobile device to help them say I love
you oh those with a special someone they
love to their mobile device to help them
say I love you those with a special
someone may look to their mobile device
to help them say I love you those with a
special someone may look to their mobile
device to help them say I love you
that's with a special someone may use
their mobile device I'll say I love you
those with a special someone may look to
their mobile device to help them say I
love you those with a special someone
may look to their mobile device to help
say I love you those with a special
someone may look to their mobile device
to help them say I love you I love you I
love you I love you I love you I love
you
i won I love you I love you I love you I
love you I love you I love you I love
you
[Applause]
I love you I love you